And now it's the old scout master.
If you haven't already been to summer camp this year, a couple of hints for you:
Don't say these two things while you're at camp, please.
Could it rain any harder?
Don't don't say that.
And and the other thing you don't want to say is: is it rain?
it can't rain all the time.
Oh well, Hey,
this is podcast number 177..
Well, welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag. We heard from Michael Harrington.
He is with troop 158 in Shrewsbury, Massachusetts
And he wrote in to say this: in the last podcast you answered an email from
someone who felt that the patrol method had its limitations.
That email and your response to it was on target with an issue our troop has
been through recently. A group of nine weevilos crossed the road
They've been through recently. A group of nine weevilos crossed over in February
And before too long a few of the parents involved with that group decided
that the patrol system just was not going to work.
They wanted a rookie training camp for the new scouts.
They wanted adults to be much more involved with what the whole troop was doing.
And I explained that we had a troop guide and we had an assistant scout
master who was looking after the new scouts to mentor them through.
but they wanted something a lot more structured and a lot more adult involved.
I resisted and the upshot is they left
The complaining adults, many of whom were former cub leaders, and one who was
an Eagle Scout decided to join an adult led troop down the road from us.
This made my fellow adult leaders here nervous
And they wondered if we needed to have more adult involvement in planning,
at meetings and on campouts. but I've got to tell you
we're going to stick with the patrol method.
We are going to train our youth leaders and let them lead their troop.
Well, good for you, Michael.
Now, what you describe as a pretty rare occurrence,
but every once in a while it's going to happen
Nearly everybody. once they get into a scout troop,
especially if they've been working in cubs, it's going to have
a little bit of an eye opener when it comes to working the patrol method
and things like that. And we've talked about this many, many times.
but good for you for standing up for your scouts.
You know, at that group that left,
check in with them in a year or so, see if they're still in scouts.
I'd be very curious to know about that.
I've had similar things happen and they don't hang around for very long.
Tony Florent wrote in on Facebook. he said:
just found the podcast in the website.
Hey, Tony, come on, we've been here forever, right?
But he said you guys rock.
Well, Tony, it's just me, but I'll. I'll take the compliment.
James Chaplin is with crew 1833 down in Haymarket, Virginia.
He said: I just got your book Thoughts on Scouting and I love it.
It's right down my street in its short, simple ideas that hold great value.
Being a scout master and being diagnosed with ADHD-
That's why I can think like an 11 year old- you and me both, James, right,
I am glued to it as I read on and I flip through the pages
and I see a lot of scout master minutes and what you wrote,
Both for troops and for my role as a trainer for future scout masters.
I've been collecting this kind of thing for years
and I'll be adding your thoughts to my collection.
Well, thank you so much, James.
I do appreciate it.
And what James is talking about there is my book,
That's right, a brand new book,
Wow, with covers and pages and just like the grown ups have.
It's called Thoughts on Scouting.
If you go to scoutmastercgcom, you'll find out how to get a copy.
It's also available on Amazon,
So you want to check that out.
This is a summer podcast.
We're taking it nice and light and easy.
I've got a couple of email questions to answer,
And the first thing we're going to do, though, is in scout
master ship, in seven minutes or less, we're going to talk about the main aim
of scouting,
So that's going to take up the rest of the entire podcast,
So let's get started, shall we scout master ship in seven minutes
or less?
In Baden Powell's writings, he talked about something called the main
aim. you know the point of it all, why we are in the business
Right, Why? why we do scouting, and aim, I think, is a particularly
well chosen term, because I remember, ages ago, when I was a archery
instructor at our scout camp. I learned pretty quickly that most
scouts were not very interested in the beginning, not very interested
in aiming really carefully or learning much about archery.
What they wanted to do is they wanted to come down and grab arrows
and a bow.
They wanted to stand on the firing line and shoot as many arrows
as possible into the target or near the target or just shoot an arrow,
Right. I mean, that was the most exciting thing
And that's what they wanted to do.
Now, after a while, I could convince them that if they would
listen for a few minutes- that you know, and they calm down a
bit, we'd go through the different steps of aiming,
And if I remember correctly, in archery I think there's nine
of them, And you know, nobody wants to hear. well, you got
to go through nine steps of this or that to really get good
at this. But after a while, if you come down and you get
patient, you begin to go through those steps and you begin
to work your way through and you find out that just leveling
the bow at the target and pulling the bow string back and
releasing it is not going to get you very far.
You have to go through the steps right.
You have to go through these different components of a good
aim and then you become a pretty good shooter.
So I think when we're involved in scouting as adults,
it's kind of the same way.
It's such an exciting prospect to work with these boys
and to get to go camping and all the skills and the
badges and all this great stuff,
And so you run right down to the firing line and you
level the bow at the target, start shooting off arrows
as quickly as you can,
And pretty soon you find out. well, I really don't have-
I don't have- that much idea of what I'm doing.
So you may back off and you may study a little bit
and get yourself trained and try and hone your skills
and soon learn about what you do,
So that our scouts get out of scouting
what was intended for them to get out of scouting.
And what is that, by the way?
Well, it's pretty simple.
I mean, there's lots and lots of different ways to say it,
but it's very, very simple,
Just off the top of my head. I'm not even.
I'm not reading anything I've written.
The main aim of scouting is to make good people right,
To make good, cooperative, active citizens
who are compassionate, decent human beings
who are going to be an asset to their family
and their society and their culture.
That's our aim.
Everything else is all just icing on the cake,
It's all details and it's not the aim.
Learning how to build a fire- okay,
Let's just break that down for a moment. okay,
Take one of these really massively important skills,
or what we think is massively important.
Learning how to build a campfire, okay,
Well, we can send people off into adulthood
having learned how to build a campfire
and a hundred other really important scout skills,
And, yeah, will they have benefited?
Yeah, somewhat, but we haven't reached the main aim
if that's all we send them with right.
So why are we out in the woods camping around?
Why are we building campfires and things like that
if our main aim is not that?
Well, because we know that the process of getting out
into the woods to go camping
are the process of building a campfire
and cooking your food over it and setting up a tent
and sleeping overnight in the woods
and working with your patrol.
We know that that process achieves the main aim.
So what should you be keeping your eye on as a scout leader?
What should you be thinking about all the time?
Think about what you're aiming at.
Now, when I was an archery instructor,
I had a guy come down
and those of you who are familiar with archery
would know about traditional archery
and there's a technique in archery called
of aiming, an archery called the instinctive technique.
It's not very scientific
Basically, it's just kind of this Zen type thing
where you center in on the center of the target
and everything. and a young man come down
with his traditional archery kit
and he used the range
and he was just drilling the center
out of the archery target.
And I talked to him and I said:
tell me a little bit about this instinctive aiming technique.
I said what? just walk me through it,
Tell me what you're doing.
He says, well, there's an X in the middle of the target
And I picture that X
and I line up everything and I shoot for that X.
I said what? X in the middle of the target?
And so we walk the 20 feet down to the targets
and, yes, in the middle of this printed target
was about a quarter inch tall X,
a little black X, about a quarter of an inch tall.
I had never really even seen it before
and from 20 feet away I doubt anybody could see it,
but he knew it was there.
I say that to say this:
you're aiming at something
that you can't necessarily see,
but instinctively you know what it is,
and that is to build a decent human being.
After you've been through this for a few years,
you're gonna have a better instincts,
You're gonna have more experience,
but just don't get hung up
in all of the other things you know.
Yes, when it's your turn to instruct,
instruct effectively. when it's your turn
to evaluate, evaluate effectively.
when it's your turn to do any of the other things,
do them effectively.
But remember there's one aim, and one aim only,
and that's what you need to concentrate on.
Once you do that, you stop getting frustrated,
You stop getting caught up in the thousand little details
and you start paying attention to the process,
and that makes you a happier scouter,
and happier scouters have happier scouts.
We don't doubt about it.
I wanna jump up and scream and shout it:
Oh, get ready for uniform.
cause, baby, I was born to be a scout.
Oh, cause, baby, I was born to be a whoop.
Here comes the scout master
driver. John the scout will be a little faster.
Stick on the gas. are we there yet?
I wanna build a bridge for my eagle project.
Find me a letter, send it by name.
Email, that is, folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
We got an email from Scott Anderson,
who is with a scout troop in Shoreview, Minnesota,
And Scott says this first: wow
And thank you.
Stumbled onto your site
and it's just filled with great info.
Little overwhelming to find it all in one place.
I stepped into the position of scout master
about one year ago.
The previous scout master
had held the position for 22 years
Now. those years of consistent leadership were very positive
but, as you might imagine,
they led to this kind of creeping influence
of adult leaders and a little bit of stagnation.
So, as a new scout master,
I wanted to make some changes,
Chiefly to restore the patrol method,
And I'm getting some resistance
from some of the old assistant scout masters,
some of the old guard,
with having the senior patrol leader
point positions of responsibility
and sign off rank requirements.
They think if we let scouts sign off on requirements
they're just gonna let things slide.
I don't agree.
I think that their peers are a little tougher on them
than any adult would be.
Reading through a little bit of your website,
I was wondering what your take would be on those issues.
Thanks again for publishing the website.
I have spent untold hours
researching this type of thing all over the web
all we know to find it consolidated
into one really useful site.
Well, Scott, thanks for your kind words
and thanks for getting in touch.
Sounds like, as a new scout master,
you're making things happen, and good on you for that.
You're right about the senior patrol leader.
The senior patrol leader
appoints the quarter master and the scribe
and things like that.
You know. of course, the patrol leaders
are elected by the scouts and their patrol
And that's straight out of the scout master handbook.
So why anybody would be pushing you on that one,
You know? I don't know what their beef would be
about that.
And I think if you pointed out to them
in the scout master handbook,
maybe they'll change their minds.
And if they don't change their minds,
point it out to them and say
this is what we're doing anyway and just move on ahead.
Scouts signing requirements for other scouts-
that's permitted to and it's good practice.
I will tell you this: getting a requirement signed
has nothing to do with anyone being tough
or anyone letting somebody else slide by on something.
I mean, what is advancement all about
Is: are we doing the whole advancement system
because it's especially important that
to the future, that our scouts
know how to build campfires and tie knots?
If that's all we had in mind, it would be kind of silly.
We use advancement because, as I just spoke about,
it's a process through which our scouts grow
into these decent people that we wanna make,
who learn to think for themselves
and then develop an internal standard of honor and service.
The skills that we use as a part of this process
are really nowhere near as important as the process itself.
When scouts sign requirements for other scouts,
think about the kind of processes that work there.
Think about the interpersonal dynamics in play,
the kind of judgment and responsibility being practiced,
Something that is being denied to them
if adults are the only ones allowed
to sign off requirements.
The skill and the level of skill isn't as important
as the process of learning and testing and judgment
and working with others.
That's why scouts should be signing requirements.
I hope that helps, and good on you again, Scott,
for being a good scout master
and using the patrol method.
Dawn is an adult volunteer with a scout troop in Virginia
and she wrote in to ask:
is it appropriate for Eagle Scout Master Conferences
to be in the private home of the scout master?
It just doesn't seem right to me.
Well, Dawn, thanks for getting in touch
and kudos for recognizing a potentially bad situation.
If you're an adult volunteer,
you've been through youth protection
and you hear that conferences are being held
at the scout master's home
and that may make you feel a little bit uneasy,
and that uneasy feeling should direct you
to make sure that things are above board
and being done properly.
If you go and look at the youth protection guidelines,
the simple answer to your question-
is it appropriate for an Eagle Scout Master Conference
to be held at the scout master's house?
You know, the simple answer is yes,
but there are some very important qualifications
to that answer.
Youth protection guidelines specify
that there is never to be any one-on-one contact
between an adult and a scout.
One-on-one contact is defined as a discussion or a meeting
or anything that is exclusively between an adult and a scout,
not being observed or shared with a third person.
If the scout is invited to the scout master's home
and the scout master's family is at home-
his wife or his children are at home,
or the scout is accompanied by a parent or a fellow scout
and the conversation takes place
where it can be observed by others,
It's within youth protection guidelines.
If those conditions aren't present,
then someone needs to report this
to their council executive.
That's right. just report it to the council executive,
Who will do all the work
that they are paid to do. at that point,
If you don't know exactly what's going on,
I'd encourage you to ask the scout
or the scout master about this
and assure yourself that youth protection
is being followed. and that's a very simple question.
If you're talking to the scout,
say: I understand you visited Mr So-and-So's house
for your Eagle Conference.
Can you tell me who was there
And could you tell me where you had the Eagle Conference?
Okay, and you can ask the scout master the same thing
You can say. I heard John came over to your house.
Were you two the only people at your house
or did he bring a buddy with him?
I don't think that those are improper questions to ask.
Good on you, Dawn, for having recognized
a potentially dangerous situation,
or just follow it through and check it up.
Nobody should ever be offended
by somebody asking those sorts of questions,
because we're all committed to youth protection
and to following youth protection guidelines.
If you wanna get in touch with me,
if you have a question for me, you can email me,
and you're gonna find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this edition
of the Scout Master Podcast.
Here's how you can keep in touch:
Read the Scout Master blog at scoutmastercgcom
And, while you're there, you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can subscribe to the Scout Master podcast on iTunes
and, when you do, you know, leave a comment
or review a rating. those are always appreciated.
You can also access the podcast on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio,
and you can get details about how to make that happen
at stitchercom.
All the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
are available through the vast panorama of social media.
That's right.
Join the 3,500 other fans on Scout Master blog on Facebook.
Tweet Scout Master CG on Twitter,
Watch us over on YouTube at Scout Master CG,
and we even have a Scout Master CG circle
for those of you who are on Google+.
Now, if none of that appeals to you,
well, you can always go back to good old fashioned email.
That's right. zoom into the late 90s
and email me, Clark Green, your comments and questions
at clarkclarke at scoutmastercgcom.
The Scout Master blog and the Scout Master podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and maybe even have a little bit of fun along the way.
So before we go, let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir?
Until next time.